[Music]
I'd say I'm a pretty advanced angular
user so when I first saw that there was
a desktop-based
app for the angular CLI my initial
thought was I probably don't have any
need for that but then I actually used
it and was very surprised at the
productivity gains I got out of it over
the next few minutes I'll take you
through all the core features of the
angular console and explain why I think
it's a powerful tool for developers of
all skill levels if you're new here like
and subscribe and you can find the full
write-up at angular firebase.com
the angular console is built by Narwhal
and it's an electron app that provides a
graphical user interface for the angular
COI
it's currently available on Mac and
Windows but there should be a linux
version available in the future go ahead
and download it onto your system open it
and then the first thing you'll do is
just select a directory to create a new
project or you can import an existing
project I'm going to go ahead and create
a new project the first thing I'll do is
give it a name and then we can select
the set of schematics that we want to
use for this project you have the option
for an X here but I'll just be using the
regular angular CLI schematics for now
that's going to create a new project
with the CLI and then you'll see we get
the output from the command line
directly in the app here when that's
done we can open up our project in the
IDE you can see I have a link here for
vs code up in the top right I'll go
ahead and keep vs code opened up here on
the right for the rest of the video one
of the reasons this app is really good
for productivity is because the angular
CLI is just so complex there's so many
different options and generators it's
hard to keep track of everything
clicking a set of buttons tends to be a
lot faster than trying to memorize and
type out every single command for
example if we want to serve an app we
can just hit the serve button and then
we have a set of options here plus a
couple of default configurations and
everything is documented for you right
here so you know exactly what each knob
does without having to go search through
the documentation serving an app is
pretty simple but when you get into
generators for components and modules
there are dozens of different options
and it's impossible to memorize all of
them let's see how quickly we can set up
a shared module here I'll go to the
module generator and then we fill out
the required fields such as the
The Associated project and then we'll
also go ahead and import this module
into our existing app module and you'll
also see in the console it executes say
dry run of the command before you click
generate so you'll know if there are any
issues before you actually run this
command when we click generate it sets
up the shared module as expected in our
app directory but right now it's empty
so let's go ahead and add some
components to it one of my favorite
things about the console is that it will
automatically detect this module so now
we can add components to it easily just
by clicking that module in the UI typing
out the path to a module from the
command line is pretty tedious and
error-prone so this UI just makes your
life a lot easier in that regard then
just for fun we'll go ahead and set some
random optional fields and you can see
the command below gets really long the
CLI commands probably like 200
characters which is not something that
you want to be typing out by hand if we
go ahead and click generate you'll see
that component gets added to our shared
module with all the various options that
we selected the console can also run
your npm scripts if you look over here
on the right i'm creating my own custom
script that just says say hello and
we'll just have it echo my name back
then if you watch over on the left side
as soon as i create it it shows up in my
package.json scripts here in the angular
console then we can just go ahead and
click run and it echos my name back as
expected now there's one more thing in
the console I want to show you that I
think is extremely useful but will
become even more useful in the future as
more third-party schematics or created
one of the new features in angular 6 was
the ability to use ng add which allows
developers to add third-party libraries
to their existing project without any
setup if you click on the puzzle piece
you'll see a registry of a whole bunch
of different third-party schematics such
as ng rx native script kendo UI and a
bunch of others what I really like about
this is that everything is centralized
in a single place so I don't have to go
searching on Google for different
schematics offered by different third
parties so a simple example of using ng
add would be if you want to add ng rx
store to your app you simply click on
the schematic run it and you'll see our
actual code gets updated with a store
module in the app
Plus installs all of the ng RX
dependencies a growing area in the
angular ecosystem is the use of
third-party schematics which are
essentially mods for the angular CLI a
good example would be native script if
you're building a native mobile app you
can generate components that are
suitable for ios and android so let's go
ahead and add the native script
schematics to our project you'll notice
that updates are package.json with a
couple of new scripts that we can run
from the console but it also gives us a
whole nother set of generators
specifically for native script if you
click on the code icon you'll see we now
have schematics for the angular CLI plus
native script and overall they look
similar but they do different things so
let's go ahead and generate a component
for native script you'll notice a
handful of different options based on
the platform that you're targeting
and when you generate the component if
you look at the code you'll notice some
slight differences such as the TNS
extension and also a component that has
a native widget instead of just plain
HTML I'm gonna go ahead and wrap things
up there I'm sure they'll be adding
additional features to the console in
the future but it's already a great
productivity booster in its current
state so you'll probably see me using it
on future videos if you're building an
angular firebase app and looking to get
that app into production as soon as
possible consider signing up for a pro
membership at angular firebase com
you'll get access to full courses and
advanced content designed to help you
build and ship your app faster thanks
for watching and I'll talk to you soon